une production du studio sfr en 2008
bienvenue au sans fil
le podcast où on parle de ce qu'on veut
avec nos invités
bah si tu pêches convaincre moi de me
plante notre semaine parce qu'elle sans
filtre est présenté par planté sa fatwa
de mai à faire tu prends en despote ben
dépourvu c'est que j'applaudis je
blaguais une artiste avec le travail que
je trouve extraordinaire qui s'appelle
orient droit à rien droits d'auteur
compositeur de québec de sport jeune 22
ans on a fait une toune ensemble
s'appelle adele qui est déjà disponible
depuis un petit bout qui sorti l'an
passé de la borne sur spotify itunes
vous allez voir et l'écouter cette pièce
le adèle ses huit réalisations faites
moi j'ai enregistré on a rangé la toune
ensemble en fait on va travailler
ensemble on fait tout la coréalisation
puis s'est moqué mixer juge ou lecteur
là dessus mais est vraiment la bonne
elle écrit vraiment des bonnes thoune
attendu par belle voix qui dans le fond
il ya un nouveau projet qui s'en vient
avec elle d'ailleurs dans quelques
semaines une nouvelle toune et qui
s'appelle le ciel est en place qui va
sortir par stay tune pour ce puits est
un mini album qui s'en vient une artiste
à surveiller à découvrir est vraiment
excellente puis moi je crois beaucoup en
est elle dans son projet puis jeu très
content farm et musique avec el faqih
map log aujourd'hui c'est rien droit
excellente plug l'excellent blog sur le
sans filtre cette semaine ouais on ne
reçut une fille fille sans 8108 merci
une fille passe encore et encore ouais
parce que on a reçu quelques un autre
roi entre moi et mes droits et mes le
roi qui est
youtube a créé dans le contenu est tout
tout tout seul nom est vraiment lui
c'est vraiment vraiment scindé entre les
deux il crée du contenu et du contenu de
qualité d'extrême qualité
c'est en fait très peu sur le contenu de
grande qualité on aime beaucoup c'est
quelqu'un qui vaut pout c'est justement
dans ces vidéos la recherche la
réflexion un peu plus loin tu vas
falloir vraiment faire quelque chose qui
qui qui qui tout il sait qu'il va faire
une différence pour les scènes marque
il s'est fait beaucoup connaître avec
des vidéos que fait sur l'environnement
qui on est et qui ont été virés vraiment
gros sur youtube encore plus sur
facebook ça a probablement vu ces vidéos
la passe et d'apprendre à écouter ces
vidéos là les vidéos qui ont été faites
avec une bonne recherche de bonnes
rigueur puis tu vois que c'est un sujet
maintenant qu'il maîtrise qu'il connaît
bien puisqu'il va aussi vraiment
beaucoup mettre de l'emphase sur les
solutions qu'on pourra porter à au
problème du changement climatique
donc c'est vraiment pas d'casqué tourner
autour de ce sujet le des changements
climatiques
puis nous nous aussi on sache à
conserver mails on a fait nos petites
recherches puis c'est ça je pense qu'on
offre une on est chacun humblement pas
expert en la matière mais je pense qu'on
a bien exposé premièrement le problème
puis aussi certaines pistes
cette hantise des solutions certaines
pistes de réflexion sur ces thèmes-là
donc j'espère que vous allez apprécier
moi je pense moi je trouve que ça pas de
casque qui vraiment un bon prof en fait
vraiment pas qu'à ce que je trouve que
vient faire un bon travail fait un bon
travail
dernièrement on réalise à quel point les
gens qui écoutent le sans fil vous êtes
vous êtes géniaux on le voit dans les
commentaires que vous faites on voit
dans la nuance que vous avez on le voit
dans le respect surtout que vous avez
dans vos commentaires
évidemment tout le temps quelques
commentaires de mauron on les prend pas
en compte parce que vous êtes vraiment
une belle communauté
c'est fou qu'on puisse avoir des
conversations je réalise on dirait en
parlant à voir qu'on puisse avoir des
conversations de 1h30 à 2h de qualité
puis que vous embarquez avec nous que
vous suiviez c'est un honneur pour vrai
pisam jam touche peas et hop ça me rend
optimiste pour ce genre de contenu le en
fait qu'on fait sur le web d'ampleur pas
grand pont sans me fait continuer de soi
pour dire continuez à commenter les
podcasts quand on a participé à la
discussion
on lit honnêtement quasiment tous les
commentaires enfin si vous écrivez en
commentaire définitivement peut-être
qu'on répondra pas systématiquement mais
on va définitivement lire les
commentaires puis abonnez vous à nos
chaînes parler de la bonne nouvelle par
thalès aa vos amis elle faisait encore
de plus en plus écoutée le sans-fil tu
fais qu on continue dans ce sens le fait
que sans plus attendre
bon bah de caste bonne écoute
[Musique]
yes man fait qu'encore une fois je
ritter la bienvenue puis le merci
d'avoir accepté c'était quand même chose
nautisme est reprise la semaine
prochaine c'est que la semaine prochaine
c'est qu'il faut écouter spa en plus ont
tort subi certaines vidéos je pense on
entend on entend un bouquet sur une
vidéo comme deux jours après les années
les années 2000 et 2007 - c'est vraiment
merci beaucoup pour vrai félicitations
aussi pour la qualité mais notons
contenu parce que pour beaucoup de
contenu beaucoup tourner une qualité
il ya aussi beaucoup du scrap sur
l'internet je trouve que toi tu es tu
réussis à faire de quoi qui est vraiment
qualitatif mais c'est très gentil merci
beaucoup je pense que je suis pas le
seul du tout lors du tout non non je
dirais moi moi je suis tellement inspiré
par beaucoup de choses que je vois sur
internet et au québec et à
l'international qui que je trouve
tellement qualitative tellement
pertinent il est tellement d'aider des
gens qui sont genre tout seul chez eux
genre dans leur sous sol puis qui fondit
qui font la recherche puis du contenu
qui sont comme tu dis il faut aussi tout
seul après que des équipes de 10 15
personnes dans des métiers traditionnels
qui font pour moi même pas connu d'aussi
bonne qualité que c'est qu'un psy foot
cette révolution avec internet justin
fashanu si c'est justement il ya toute
la recherche de la qualité qui est l'up
d'efforts garde contenu pour l'école
soyons pourquoi safer l'oeil et plus de
gens qui ont regardé ce qu'on voit c'est
tellement bon ben c'est tellement
pertinent mais tout et 14 étaient
capables de justement d'allier contenu
informatif pertinent important avec
rejoindre un auditoire notamment un bon
outil store merci
ce qui a fait exploser d'achêne c'est un
vidéo le l'année dernière sur
l'environnement ou est-ce que je pense
qu'on vidéo s'appelle il est déjà trop
tard pour le premier exact le premier
point sur l'environnement ça plaît il
est déjà trop tard pour l'environnement
alors quoi faire je m'assure que
il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde qui nous
écoutent en ce moment qu'ils n'ont pas
su soient écoutés ou vu passer dans leur
fille
que ce soit sur facebook ou dans leurs
recommandations you do ba c'est vraiment
été viral sur facebook qu'elle était
incroyable aussi un ccd 12 ces deux
vidéos la première c'est le pineau que
j'ai fait un mois plus tard qui avec la
la la pilule rouge l'exode les beaucoup
de gens me voient parler de ces pilules
là j'ai comme un ver c'est parce que
dans matrix la rouge c'est celle qu'il
faut prendre puis moi dans ma vidéo
c'est la bleue il faut prendre avec qui
j'en étais j'ai vu ce qu'était que je
mets en battant vidéo sauf simple fait
que lancer ces deux vidéos que j'ai fait
un mois d'intervalle qui ont tous les
toutes les deux un peu et et virales sur
facebook notamment puis un peu sur
youtube ici et moi en fait la première
vidéo c'est très drôle
la première vidéo je défends une journée
dans la zone de l'idée à la rue à la
recherche elle crie dessus à tout publie
la vidéo une journée ah ouais parce que
moi ça faisait des mois comme beaucoup
de gens que je me disais ah qu'est
l'environnement il faut que je m'y comme
je m'y attarde
vendredi le chef et j'étais juste tombés
comme si ce que j'ai dans la vidéo en
fait dans la première vidéo c'est que je
tombe sur un article selon une étude
d'un professeur jam band le scientifique
et son étude s'appelle des partitions
c'est que lui la fosse qui disait qu'il
faudrait faire une adaptation très
profonde du système pour pouvoir
inverser ou du moins les changements
climatiques s'adapter aux changements
climatiques il faudrait vraiment faire
une grosse grosse adaptation c'est ce
qu'ils disent moi ça m'a vraiment comme
son article est vraiment intense je
conseille à tous lecture à cette
personne
cc ou que te trouver ce commun comment
cela se résume alors je pensais comme un
truc genre device sur facebook en
arctique qui re qui relierait diriger
vers ce seul exemple puis
samassa va raccrocher j'ai lu puis à
partir de cette étude le j'ai fait un
petit peu plus de recherche dans la même
journée puis ça donnait cette vidéo que
j'ai fait vraiment rapidement un peu
moins coûteuse que j'ai filmé soi-même
et mis en ligne le lendemain matin et
j'ai été propulsé dans cette danse dans
ce phénomène le avec un grand plaisir et
apprécié j'ai fait plus de recherches
pendant un mois pour la deuxième vidéo
s'attendait pas à ce que cette vidéo là
et c'est un impact luxe est porté leurs
enfants ou tout sans se douter mais on
peut se douter que c'est le sujet
justement qui préoccupe je pense au
point de vue le titre de large échelle
les jeunes pilotes ce site en ce moment
mais je pense que c'est tout le monde
s'entend pour dire que tout le monde
s'entend mais beaucoup de gens
s'entendent pour dire que c'est les
défis du 21e siècle
les changements climatiques mais en fait
c'est une bonne nouvelle je pense que je
te mange les gens soient aussi réceptifs
et aussi intéressés par ce sujet là
parce qu'on aurait pu aussi justement
rester dans le déni comme titi vidéo
décidé ne pas regarder ou pas le
partager je pense que je peux c'est un
espoir parce que les sports et du seul à
avoir des attentes mais au moins je
pense que tout le monde ou presque tout
le monde a envie de faire quelque chose
voilà par l'environnement on est tous un
peu on sent coupable tout se préparant à
la crise environnementale et qu'on voit
des trucs passé
sur facebook ou dans les médias qui
pendent environnement ou qui relaient
des informations sur l'environnement et
sur peut-être même des actions qu'on
pourrait faire les gens sales et rejoint
énorme et moi j'ai moi j'ai remarqué
c'est par rapport à l'environnement ça
rejoint les gens vraiment beaucoup on
s'attache à l'environnement on prend des
gens comme crittenton burg et on s'est
vraiment foulé la portée que ces gens là
ont les gens ils prennent déjà il
s'attache à lui il dissipe est une
solution c'est peut-être une façon de sa
nation et sa vie est vraiment les
chercher profondément et quand il est
donc dès qu'on traverse par rapport à
l'environnement sa vie encore plus les
chercher les contrats version de vue à
l'anis à controverse 1
c'était par rapport à l'environnement on
a vu comment ça ça crée quelque chose de
défendre les gens vraiment pris ce un
peu comme une occasion d'aider comme se
défouler joint ses salles à la serbie un
petit peu de bouc émissaire est quelque
chose qui est beaucoup plus gros exact
je crois que tout le monde qui
reprochaient des incohérences plus je
défends pas du tout ce sont son manque
de jugement mettons dans cette situation
le met tout le monde qui reprochaient
une incohérence
j'ai l'impression que c'était pour un
petit peu détourné le miroir de leur
propre visage puis de leurs propres
incohérences parce que j'ai vu une liste
heureusement sans fin des personnalités
publiques qui critiquait à l'anis pis
ces actions qui al de leur profession
agissent vraiment pas mieux que
l'exemple qui me vient en tête c'est
pileux c'est un exemple parmi tant
d'autres mais c'est bien lui que
pierre-luc phong pardon kiwis qui
critiquait beaucoup à la mise sur son
sur son manque de pertinence sur sa page
privée facebook
chami avec les piges et j'ai vu ce passé
ça a été repris
vraiment beaucoup mais
et c'est un avocat pour pour
l'environnement pire look funky en
paroles y en a parlé pendant la campagne
aura été excellent jeune génération puis
pop tort que avant un des vidéos à toi
que je regardais cette semaine une peu
mcdonald's big mac extra beken lycée
pierre luc funky et loti fait quelle est
la différence entre parler
d'environnement pendant la campagne
électorale et après surfer une pub de
mecs dobkine puis qu'après ce faire
parler d'environnement faire une pub des
sceaux mec dos dans le top 10 des
industries les plus polluantes au monde
il y en a pas du tout outil fait que je
pense que le monde reprocher à beaucoup
à l'anis son manque de cohérence mais je
crois que tout le monde dans un énorme
incohérence puis c'est pas mal
intentionnés non c'est seul le point
principal du à l'anis qu'un café twitter
en disant qu'à le port pour la planète
c'est vrai c'est très possiblement sol
et c'était super c'est à ce moment loin
puis tout le monde qui partage ta vidéo
à toi tout le monde qui s'inquiètent
tout le monde qui vaut à nant rue pour
marcher avec greta tout le monde
s'inquiète réellement maintenant tout le
monde est incohérent dans cette
inquiétude la personne prend tous les
moyens de ses ambitions
et puis les acteurs c'est comme tu dis
pierre-luc funky la pub 2012 mais il ya
tellement d'acteurs qui ont fait des
dépôts pour des autos mais est il plus
jamais controverse avec ce diamètre lyon
mais celles qui demandent s'il n'y a pas
que du monde signé le pacte qui faisait
des pubs pour les voitures et on les
aime pas non plus le mythe
[Rires]
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de trucs on lit
plus on est plutôt layrac les acteurs
parce que c'est comme si on était
habitués qui jouent des rôles fait que
quand ils font une pub si presque comme
s'ils jouaient un rôle du pôle emploi en
même temps si on dit pas et guillaume
lemay thivierge et vient jouer le rôle
de jackie qui est un gag du midwest
américain
c'est comme vient faire guillaume lemay
thivierge dans une peu pourquoi parce
que tu es guillaume lemay thivierge ses
sketches très présent exact c'est puis
moi ça je pense que l'on devrait autant
les politiques doit que les gens qu'on
pointe du doigt sur internet et je
trouve qu'un déséquilibre street à
charbon vers fait puis les influenceurs
devient aussi la tête de turc de dollars
dont les médias traditionnels se sent
peut-être leur groupe sur les sur la la
place publique commence à s'en aller à
gauche je pense que c'est des pros
facile de france entonnait maison maison
surtout surtout que steam et ont pour
pour atteindre tu sais partons perle
pour atteindre un certain niveau de
pertinence sur la place publique des
médias traditionnels il ya beaucoup
d'étapes pour ceux en a pour se rendre
loeb 6e étape le fond un genre de tri de
après quatre mauvaises décisions ça se
peut que tu te rendes peur ou est ce que
tu as à l'été sur internet en direct le
droit infinie de mauvaises décisions
puis quand même être suis vite je trouve
que les critiques des influenceurs oeil
une catégorie critique que j'approuve
entièrement pour ça que je suis moi il
semblait manquer des gens qui qui quand
on entendrait plus parler d'eux dans
deux trois ans puisse y ses trilles
effectivement d'aider le public à faire
le tri avec le temps le 6 mai
après aussi je trouve beaucoup de gens
qui critiquent comme on disait parce que
c'est des boucs émissaires paraissent un
nouveau phénomène parce que c'est parce
que sinon il faut parler d'eux fait que
c'est facile les critiques et puis c'est
facile de beaucoup d'articles ces temps
ci comme dans la presse avec le fisc ou
plus loin billes et je trouve ça dommage
des crises qui complètement le feu des
critiques
l'ensemble de ces gens le grandit de
mois comme c'est constamment et surtout
que c'est pas classique quoi d
influencer le mot je n'aime pas ce mot
lemay et personnes vraiment un symbole
influenceurs dit que m'a paru et c'est
quoi une influence parce que c'est juste
les gens qui font de la pub sur
instagram est ce que si tous les gens
qui font des trucs sur internet ce que
sait déjà qui influence parce que la
connotation du mot influencé peut être
extrêmement positives aussi quand tu le
fais comme toi tu le fais maintenant ccp
cloutier qui est fait une publication
sur facebook tu le sans doute vu passer
parce qu'il nomme dedans ou est ce qui
explique on s'attarde beaucoup aux
personnalités du web qu'en cdd coût
négatif cd manque de jugement comment
s'organise mais quand tu toi tu gagnes
un prix pour le contenu que tu crées je
pensais en ontario de c'est quoi le
rapport fera trop tôt c'est un prix
pourtant convenu kiki qui dans le fond
c'est quoi le prix ce qui nous faisait
faire court métrage appel j'écris ma vie
en fait et ce qui est sur youtube qu'est
ce qu'ils sont ma chaîne youtube etc
seul prix la cinématographie donc c'est
comme la la meilleure direction photo et
que mon acteur photo fils qui est elle
aussi à toronto piste et c'était super
cool parce que nous on était trois
créateurs francophones y avait aussi
rose à l'île des soeurs et frères bastié
et on était tous les trois il y avait
comme 70 vidéo de partout entre le monde
en anglais compter les trois seuls tu
fais des petites vidéos en français puis
tout le monde nous disait honnêtement et
vous invitez métier c'est ce qu'on
retient français pour vérifier qu'il est
la mère ce exact la diversité puis
finalement tu étais comme l'a fait un
galet de bris mythe et comme on va y
aller mais bon quand gros rien elle est
réputée c'était clair pour tout le monde
en pinot le titre a été extrêmement
surpris par un vote des du public puis
des gens qui ont été dans les festivals
et tous et des grands esprits le tester
c'était une grande surprise et très très
cool pour l'équipe de ce court métrage
le papier examen félicitations pour ce
merci beaucoup puisque pierre loubière
le cap est l outil dit c'est que si on
n'en parle pas on n'en parle pas du tout
mon cas quand du contenu de qualité
reconnue à l'international
on n'en parle pas parce que c'est sur le
web
sic mais cloud dans tout bon là on parle
d'un dispositif aussi dans les médias
dans le maudit positif est que cc c'est
plus difficile pour des journaux surtout
aujourd'hui parce que c'est aujourd'hui
du clip baby beaucoup et c'est plus
difficile de prévoir des choses
positives
en général un article qui retient la
news va toujours être plus luc pilartz
effet le site exact les articles
critiques elles en expliquent
d'influenceurs tout le monde et
partagent les articles de richard
martineau tout le monde partage et les
trucs négatifs puisque tous les trucs
qui font vraiment qui choque les qui
font contre eux veulent c'est ce qu'ils
ont beaucoup de clics puis aujourd'hui
les clics c'est la pulpe et la pub cc
rémunérer les gens fake
les chroniqueurs jaune au journal de
montréal et je le sais parce que moi bon
ils m'ont déjà approché jean mémorial
pour quelque chose dit vidéo avec eux et
simon expliquant ça fonctionnait
la rémunération d'un faux lyon 10 plus
beaux jeux sur les gens là de montréal
sur le site et les gens qui font des
articles
ils sont payés oui leur salaire fixe
pour beaucoup de gens mais aussi un
salaire qui dépendent du nombre des
clics et elles sont là c'est un article
pour les chroniqueurs plus tu cliques
d'un revenu c'est krencker à la
commission synchro fake je sais pas si
comme ça pour tous les chroniqueurs mois
ce qui m'avait proposé puis je pense il
m'avait dit aussi que c'est bon j'ai dit
à autre chose je sais pas si c'est légal
ce que je dis c'est pas grave on fait
sans filtre le choix s'est connu de
façon toute limite beaucoup de médias
qui fait aussi ça fait du sens ouais
fait que fixer eux les chroniqueurs ils
ont envie d'avoir des clics et fait
qu'ils vont pas gêné pour faire la
contreverse d'intelligent partage sur
facebook principe du clic bytes et
cesser dans tout le maintenant de plus
le choix même cette tva sports
maintenant qu'ils font des articles
higuain sur facebook c'est moche je
suivais des pages sur facebook pour être
mis à jour deux comme les dernières
transactions la ligue nationale mais là
c'est jean charles hudon vous croirez
pas ce qui est dit à claude julien pleut
c'est faux que tu cliques pour savoir
qu'est ce qu'il a dit qu'il ne connaît
vraiment banal c'est sûr c'est sur piste
et puis en même temps en même temps je
fais la même chose là on a un blog avec
sur vegan les peuples avec ma blonde et
un article s'appelle je m'ennuie de la
viande
vilaceca mena pourquoi ils sont et il
faut que tu cliques là dessus pour
savoir moi j'avais entendu je sais pas
si c'est vrai le quément et on sait
qu'un 400 martineau richard martineau
avant l'été aux voies étaient plus à
gauche et puis équipés des choses qui
avec un peu plus de bon sens intervenant
le mariage au début c chronique juste a
menti le avec la nouvelle direction plus
il était très affecté par les comptes en
négatif qui avait été
peut-être voir s'est pas trompé dit et
fonctionne pas un petit jeu peut pas
continuer comme ça parce qu'il y avait
trop de commentaires négatifs qui
dérange
puis selon la légende c'est pas tolérer
digard ne soit pas là dessus toi tu
t'arranges par une vedette pour que
cette affaire se partage c'est tout ce
que tu t'occupes des restes en foot et
bien mais comment accepter cette
nouvelle directive l'europe il écrit des
affaires c'est clair que qui sont sur le
but cac écrit ce gars là et bien
d'autres oui c'est d'abord le plus de
partager des actions pâtissent pas de
faire la ruche tout de faire le propos
le plus nuancée ou le plus étoffé où le
mieux rechercher s'est passé du temps en
temps tu sais c'est clairement le but de
susciter le plus grand nombre des
réactions n'importe quoi mais par contre
oui toute la pub négatif ou positif
c'est de la pub social ils le savent
c'est l'espèce de cris d'agonie d'un de
médium en déclin tient carrément cessé
ses médiums qui sait plus comment se
rémunérer parce que le papier ont rompu
parce que la pub sur internet c'est
encore très nouveau marginal et beaucoup
de revenus qui sont avec ses skis se
créent comme pas de sens parce que tout
le monde sait ça comme pas de sens que
les compagnies sont encore prêts à
investir des sommes faramineuses à radio
et tv
kan qui est autant connu qui se consomme
sous louait parce que ça c'est le sujet
ça me dépasse mais il ya encore un grand
l'absurdité déjà les ressources qu'ils
ont dans les médias traditionnels
à la télé à la radio journaux versus les
ressources mises sur internet pour le
nombre des gens qui cosigne sur des
ressources pas exponentiellement plus
élevé que ce que nous on pourrait
espérer en interne est de même pour des
projets qui sont comme pertinent
bissieux qu'on essaie de produits ou
qu'on essaierait de trouver des gens
pour investir de l'argent tu aimais tant
des courts métrages ou des projets
documentaires des scieries et que je
devais faire sur internet
je prépare ou très difficilement trouver
des façons de le produire en quarantaine
dans ce que dans les médias
traditionnels pour le à peu près
peut-être la même nombre des gens qui
écoutaient
la série à la fin on peut trouver des
ressources incroyables et west ham à la
presse
happy mais la presse en général et le
premier tu veux mais des traditionnels
comme ceux qui meurent c'est finalement
j'ai l'impression pis probablement
qu'ils aient d'autres vont suivre le
pitch thomas le aujourd'hui encore
l'aspect des clivages entre le web et la
télévision métier dans 10 ans tous eu
une seule et même affaire
c'est déjà commencer rapidement
rapidement il y aura plus de distinction
tout va être le web qui pourrait même
temps mais mais c'est celle en ce moment
les journaux sont en mode panique qui
pilote et comme on fait n'importe quoi
pour essayer de subsister dont avoir des
chroniqueurs de pignons exact près des
portes dernièrement pipi les les
chroniqueurs d'opinion donnent aussi
leurs opinions sur le terrain demain
mais jean martineau justement il ya je t
aime parce qu'elle est en fait la
semaine passée il ya des activistes
vegan qui sont rentrés chez 12bis à
circuler partout sur wiiware condamnons
les actions ça le moment nous parler
vraiment beaucoup
richard martineau fait un article sur ce
fait que momar on voulait créer un
article comme en réponse à ce fait comme
on a décortiqué son article ici chaque
phrase est une foutaise
mais après ce fait que lui fait un
article là dessus
hier je trouvais que neuf matchs qu je
regarde pied mamadou on est morte la
personne qu'on évite pour en parler et
c'est richard martineau lcn c'est comme
pourquoi pourquoi c'est quoi ce genre il
ya personne d'autre qui était plus
proche d'un asile en quoi ça vous lire
je sais pas pour être faire j'ai pas
entendu l'entrevue parce que la cour est
de n'être qu'à relier
mais comme la semaine d'avant et non sur
le mouvement d'activistes mégane la
semaine d'après et invité ses plateaux
de sienne pour parler de maman dix ans
d'un des deux ânes ont des doutes sais
pas de quoi tu parles c'est pas mal
ou les deux ou les deux avec elle pointé
chaque jour donné son opinion sur un
sujet différent
à quel point c'est absolument certain
aucune des quotes-parts peut-être des
peuples à base comparable aux pics et
ces gens le personnel fixe prenons sur
des trucs et des gens qui font la taille
d'un lecteur là dessus sauf que toi tu
es sur ton feeling sur genre de 15
noeuds de l'argent ce que tu as fait ça
à la dcri qui va être vu et lu par pas
mal plus de morts vivants rue des
pignons avec sa wii c'est vrai t'as fait
ça pour ça les six c'est pour ce qu' il
ya quelque chose quand même des billets
dans les métiers traditionnels ou
l'elysée sociaux journalistique genre
plus calmes et qui sont aux tic
les rats qui s'agitent et exo légitime
parce que ils ont vraiment un processus
de vérification des efforts ils sont
plus calmes et rigoureux et sofia sur la
recherche sur les sources et tucson
qu'ils utilisent fait quelque chose de
drôle de bien là-dedans que
effectivement mais ton juste moi tout
seul dans mes vidéos et j'ai pas une
équipe qui double tchèque tout ce que je
dis ou qu'ils vérifient missour slim est
fake je pense qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose dans la structure des
métiers traditionnels qui compte pour
paco près jamais soulevé le 100% moi je
les fais ma maîtrise sur le nouveau
journalisme c'est un courant aux états
unis des années 60 qui ressemble pas mal
à ce que toi tu fais le titre de prendre
un sujet en profondeur puis de
l'expliquer initialement ça se faisait
par des journalistes américains dans les
journaux de façon écrite qui y avait une
certaine il y avait une instance de les
utilisations qui était le journal qui
une fois que tu lisais quelque chose qui
te retrouver dans ce ca agit c'est un
peu comme filtre d'informations
pertinentes et puis en fait je
n'apprends rien à personne en disant que
aussi c'est perdu maintenant c'est en
majeure partie puis comme tu dis c'est
problématique de dire sur le web ça se
peut qu'on ne retrouve pas au dessus
qu'est ce qui va être une instance de
légitimisation c'est maintenant tu peux
pas monétiser ce qui réellement légitime
le repas personne qui va être capable de
s'assurer de la qualité d'information
exact puis le fait aussi que des gens
font du contenu de qualité comme tu le
fais peut-être peut-être que tu es
rémunérer un petit peu par à 100 mais on
sait ce que ça représente puis ça paie
pas son loyer le fait que peut-être le
fait que les gens ont commencé à faire
du contenu de qualité qui consommaient
kit écouter gratuitement à amener un peu
ce débalancement lieu de foi et long on
peut plus on n'a plus d'argent ce qui en
a qui le font gratuitement les combats
ni mais l'on retrouve dans un espèce de
cirque ou est ce que pour avoir accès au
delà du contenu de qualité puis de
l'information légitime faut chercher un
l'information au pôle choix puis hors de
moins en moins le choix justement avec
la diversité de justement d'un peu tout
le monde crie son contenu d'être
financés par l'étude moi je pense mais
puis ça soit fait de manière
premièrement indépendante elle était un
bon paquet de conf laisse moi rire puis
vraiment vérifié par plusieurs instances
pour être gay comme cette chose le est
légitime qui est fiable encore le site
trop centralisée que ça peut créer
d'autres problèmes métier c'est
l'information qualité système existe
encore des piliers coco plaisir
l'information qui vient cet endroit le
et les livrets élus pertinentes et
rigoureuse zéro + fille à ce média par
exemple comment pas encore faire un
petit peu avec certains journaux sa
nouvelle édition mais effectivement ça
évolue puis ces journaux le ont pu de
financement demain
il faut qu'il existe encore des manières
de trouver l'info peak gold et de la
qualité
sinon si c'est juste de l'info biaiser
le gauche puis de droite qui nous arrive
un peu partout kiki qui est pas fondé
sur la libye y aussi la faire c'est
qu'on est là on est certes toujours
d'être pinho dans ce qu'on fait
moi je peux poser mes vidéos sont
complètement neutre indiquant non mais
mettons l'environnement quand je fais
des outils vidéo sur l'environnement
j'ai quand même un point de vue de
départ même si c'est quand même assez
factuel
on sait que ça existe c'est factuel j'ai
quand même envie de confirmer ce
justement l'urgence climatique qui de
confirmer que ces statistiques le son
sont urgentes sont sérieux ils sont
importants d'autres personnes pourraient
juste aller sur des on peut toujours
trouver des statistiques qui appuient
marwick opinion alors c'est quoi ton a
pignon sur la cavale de trouver des
articles sur internet qui en parle avec
le climato sceptiques pour trouver des
études des statistiques qui vont appuyer
ce qu'ils disent aux grecs c'est ça qui
bat qui est dangereux lookheed world
qu'être est très regardée dans le futur
des destitutions quand même c'est
important des institutions qui sont plus
neutres pour se forger des opinions
ensuite en ou meubles ouais tout à fait
y ranger pas céder des mers nuit de
toute ma vie parce que juste avant de me
coucher j'ai regardé des vidéos sur les
les quinze fait pour relativiser c'est
tellement bon le premier fait que ta
mère qui qui moi j'ai comme fer mais
depuis on ne sentait déjà parlant plus
mais ces gens-là faire que tu oublies
l'argent savory sais rien oui l'argent
une chose que collectivement on s'entend
pour dire ça vaut south f s
mais en réalité l'argent pour la manger
de tout habillé avec pau
ces constructions c'est une histoire
qu'on se raconte tout un sens dit
fiction on ça c'est une fiction quoi il
fallait qu'elle ressent
exane dit je puisse me connaissent et
youval noir harry ça bien sa pièce c'est
écrit en est la pièce un d eux ce qui va
être une leçon pour le 21e siècle c'est
un gars qui est mort c'est jan ceulemans
idole en fait c'est que je trouve
incroyable extrêmement pertinent et j'ai
lu ces trois livres et justement homo
sapiens entre autres et est au modélisme
ont beaucoup inspiré la vidéo pour
relativiser parce que il va noir harry
est excellent pour prendre un peu de
recul et analyser les événements
historiques beaucoup d'arbres sa pièce
mais aussi les événements du président
dans ses livres notamment dans fait une
leçon pour le 21e siècle qui est
excellent pour c'est comme si des fois
je pense important de regarder ce qui se
passe dans le monde en étant appelons le
temps d'une vision claire girl comme si
des fois je fais cette mise en scène je
me dis si des extraterrestres arrive et
qui regarde ce qui se passe dans le
monde ce serait quoi
la vision du monde holly qui savent pas
c'est quoi l'argent c'est il semble
aussi que les entreprises apprécient que
les frontières des présidents des des
religions ils ont peut-être leur propre
fiction mais je peux si on s'y fixe
hurle et c'est ce qui qui foulent sécuro
minutes de tout inventé mon le tout
inventé c'est sur le etc voilà c'est ce
que j'essaie de transmettre dans cette
vidéo des faits pour relativiser mais
moi même ça ça mais quand il prend le
temps de réfléchir à ce sexy foule
c'est une espèce de vague mais c'est
l'effet que ça m'a fait une espèce de
vague de deux remises en place d'un dans
le système dans lequel on évolue pineapp
place aussi dans l'histoire de l'univers
mais comme je pensais dans l'histoire de
la planète terre c'est ce que tu es dans
l'histoire de l'univers l'histoire de la
planète de l'univers de l'univers les
êtres humains arrivent 2 2 minutes avant
la fin de la semaine sur le sort des
leaders en une semaine on arrive à 11h58
les dimanches
une faute et il ya eu beaucoup de temps
derrière nous et il y en aura
probablement encore beaucoup devant nous
la question c'est à quel point les êtres
humains vont exister dans cette période
là on l'espère le plus longtemps
possible mais il faut qu'on compense des
actions pour encore longtemps
ce qui est fou chamakh survient
l'environnement tu aimais tant l'univers
je pense comme quelque chose comme 13
milliards d'années soit 7.8 milliards
d'années la planète terre
quelques milliards la vie sur la terre
je pensais comme 400 millions milliards
d'années l'être humain
l'homo sapiens peut-être cent mille ans
et où un maximum le mot sa pièce comme
on le connait 70-70 milan et se regarde
juste mettons l'impact que le mot
sapiens eu sur la planète pendant des
dizaines de milliers d'années est
presque nul
si j'osais on chasse et on avait un
impact sur notre environnement on avait
quand même quand même exterminer des ddd
bb race animale de mammouth de la
mégafaune qu'on a chassé mais sinon
c'est l'impact est quand même
relativement bénins
après ce jusqu'à l'ère industrielle
l'homme et ont titrisé l'humain 6 6 6 2
minutes mais à cinq secondes
on est jeune on est choqué par les
écosystèmes ses pouvoirs à un point où
est-ce qu'il ya présentement l'élite
dégâts qu'il est là roux quitte à cacher
pratiquement irréversibles à 150 ans
pour nous ce qui dans la leçon d'univers
fraction de seconde
nous avons complètement to dubai est
complètement ils subordonnent d'être
complètement way saisir ce type i les
changements climatiques c'est peu mais
pour revenir ce sens elle s est pas
une affaire de ça va mal aller bientôt
c'est comme ça va déjà mais déjà un
classique
la température la terre moyenne est déjà
augmenté je pensais déjà de confirmer ce
que de plus des recherches chez moi là
dessus je pense qu'on est déjà un des
grilles supérieur à vendre l'industriel
est ce que j'ai entendu et je propose
une vue de la température mais je peux
dire ce qu'il faut il faut pas qu'on
soit 12 degrés il faut pas qu'on croit
qu'elle en a commandé deux degrés encore
j'écoutais un des créateurs qui
s'appelle climatechange de fax à la bbc
social déjà degré supérieur à la
l'industriel selon d selon dd des
simulations par un attentat entre ont
toutes les données puis en tout cas la
tendance en 2040 ou 2050 on attendrait
1.5 sait pas plus mais beaucoup pensent
qu'il ya dans un siècle à prendre trop
insisté voici ci aurait pas de
changement ça serait catastrophique
quant au v6 cccc leucate à sion et
cataclysme les quatre ans et nous on a
de la misère à le percevoir ceux qui y
habitent et je regarde la caméra parce
que je me suis bien mais on a de la
misère à al percevoir au canada aux
états unis dans les pays développés en
france parce que c'est pas nous qui sont
touchés par ce n'est pas nous qui vont
être touchés par ce dans dix ans encore
on peut être qu'on va être touché par ce
inévitablement mais en ce moment et
c'est pour ça que c'est facile de au
quotidien un peu d'oublier ou même
d'être super active et c'est un jour
puis la semaine après à enlever notre
quotidien c'est pas très grave parce que
on les voit pas vraiment les effets
parce que c'est justement c'est les pays
sont les moins privilégiés qui sont les
premiers touchés et qu'ils sont déjà
effectivement qui ont déjà commencé à
être touchés qui ont déjà plus des
catastrophes naturelles que ayons déjà
plus d'inondations qu'il ya déjà des
migrations internes dans ces pays et
bientôt ça va être alors un l'échelle
leurs cordes beaucoup plus élevé si
migration eux ils vont des voix ces gens
là vont devoir l'équipe particulaire
leurs travaux est inondée au bangladesh
aux philippines il falloir qu'ils
trouvent des endroits où aller pis on
parle la crise des migros moment ça va
être parce que le nombre d'humains qui
habitent sur des zones côtières
c'est 20 millions voir cela sur la
planète bleue qu'elle ait pitié
justement la relocalisation c'est qu'au
musée tantôt tu le dis aussi c'est pas
une affaire qui va falloir serait
localisé éventuellement c'est comme en
louisiane et des gens qui habitaient le
puits peuvent plus habiter le tpiy si je
veux pour une anecdote personnelle
mettant le sais mais je me souviens
quand j'étais jeune on n'est pas invité
aux élèves à l'insep année leur maître
cocktail qui a mais seul souvenir que
j'ai de cette époque là c'était le
chalet qu'on avait sur le bord de la
plage puis je me suis cavell long long
de plage le thé avant de se rendre à la
mouette qu'il ne fallait marcher le lait
selon playboy pu retourner les quelques
années à ça même chalet qui nous
appartient plus une semaine d'aller voir
il faut qu'ils se mettent des sacs de
sable devant le chalet pour se protéger
des vagues parce que sinon genre le celi
vague rentrer dans jal et puis
maintenant je pense qu'aujourd'hui je
pense que cette rumeur quand même
complètement et a été abandonné parce
qu'il ait pu habiter à petit évidemment
que c'est pô juste une question de
montée des eaux brillent au sommet ue
chine questions d'évasion qui naturel
mais c'est ce phénomène là et pas juste
de la madeleine partout marseillais tu
vois que c'est con qui rejetait ya des
gens qui habitaient sur ce truc et je
veux plus a saisi des vies humaines
concrètes qui sont bouleversés ses pieds
pour les gens au bangladesh puis tokyo
qui ont juste comme une maison aux
petites baraques pic toutes leurs biens
sont le pit jour au lendemain le sait on
arrive
lampaul les mêmes chances que d'autres
états unis au coq qui peuvent se
relocaliser plus facilement fait que
c'est très très difficile pour ces gens
le sait ça c'est des vies humaines et
des familles c'est super coq ray pour
ces joueuses mais c'est qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que tes vidéos font
bien de montrer l'éventail de ses quoi
les conséquences des changements
climatiques ces projets tard il fait
plus chaud autour des grippes chaud la
liste est longue
en effet justement catastrophe
climatique mais que ce soit sécheresses
fonte on le voit en australie ça brûle
en ce moment mais ça a brûlé en grèce a
brûlé sabrina californie sa part toute
inondation inondations c'est pas une je
dois bosser après ce bain les animaux
sont capables de s'adapter parce que ça
change
extraits des espèces tous les jeunes à
tous les jours dit justement encore une
fois les sections des espèces et pau
d'affaires dehors plus tard c'est des
gens quand j'ai depuis longtemps passé
continuent d'arriver à un rythme est
effréné seul seul l'extinction des
espèces le détenteur d'un podcast c'est
vrai ce dogme bag in box effet si
réveillère plus rien faire même si
demain matin et on met en confiance 180°
complètement que les gouvernements de la
planète prennent par la main puis tout
le monde et joyeux pour faciliter lutte
la lutte aux changements climatiques
ça se fasse à 80 ben ya des espèces
j'entre au sort pour terminer ouais
c'est fou ccc pour ceux qui sont aussi
des jetons le déjà fait moins une balle
non avec autant était sauvée il est
dégueu le plus possible d'y commencer à
agir maintenant qui quand je dis
commencer à agir il nous mais il ya
énormément les industries puis le
gouvernement ça revient beaucoup
beaucoup et c'est le beau parler des
changements individuels qui sont
importants qui ont leur impact sur tout
est-ce que tu choisi d'acheter beaucoup
de ces boucles se commande concerne
mais parce que les industries des métaux
je prends l'exemple du véganisme parce
que c'est quelque chose que je suis qui
je connais beaucoup même si l'objectif
mettons moi mon objectif c'est de faire
diminuer la demande
c'est d'introduire plus d'options que
les gens puissent moins consommer de
viande parce que plus de bonnes options
c'est mais de faire diminuer la demande
pour changer l'offre
ça va prendre trop de temps fait même si
on continue à commettre
j'ai parlé de légalisme adom iran du vg
et puis on parle on si on parle de
véganisme ap le temps paraît tout à fait
logique même si on continue à ce rythme
pour faire diminuer la demande ça ce
report assez rapide se repasser temps
quelqu'un repro faire une mesure
politique pour faire un changement c'est
la même chose mais ton même même fait la
demande de voitures à essence même
ferdinand le demande d'essence quand
même ça ça se repasser you rien gâter le
changement mais ton par rapport aux
mécanismes dans la dernière année ça a
été ma siffler quasiment 150 %
d'augmentation de gens qui considèrent
de gamme dans le dernier 12 mois le tir
mais ça c'est pas un rythme même si
c'est énorme c'est pas un rythme assez
rapide
c'est pas un raid pour changer les
changements climatiques mondiaux sinon
les accès c'est pour ce que les lits
gros gros les grosses pièces de cet
article c'est les grosses industries qui
sont déjà en place des puissantes entier
mais ceci ils ont tellement pouvoir et
pouvoir politique et notamment plus ça
c'est très très très difficile et c'est
très complexe en question mais c'est
très difficile de les déloger turquie
qui prennent les décisions ils font pas
ils vont passer ses nuits notamment
puissant s'est dit nous on a voté au
canada - premier ministre qu'on
considérait 20 justin trudeau
puis on leur a été entre autres élus
pour ce parce qu'on l'eût cru on est cru
qu'ils sont tellement puissants
l'industrie que qu'est-ce que le et pour
le choix et peu le joueur humain exact
d'acheter séparer
ses pieds fauqué à quel point il ya un
double dit qu en politique
chez justin trudeau métier est ce que
dans le fond de lui-même le goût de la
chanson bahreïn j'en doute fortement
- c'est sûr que lui qu'un quidam pas le
coup de l'acheter
il ya peu le goût d'avoir la contreverse
il achève au delà d'un exil h etc
c'est parce que pas le choix imagine à
quel point qui faisait pas de tort de
l'abri pour l'acheter quel point
mais quel point il n'y a pas le choix
pas quel point c'est ce masque sait sur
qui personne qui va avoir la d'un
policier qui dit une chose et fait le
contraire ici par la dette se mais
malgré ce il fait potentiellement même
au fond de lui en tant que personne
probablement que sa décision mais c'est
de croire en scénic est demandé de dire
à qui secoue le pouvoir que ces genres
le 11ème ses fans qui épie puis pourquoi
les pourquoi le changement se fait si
lentement
et puis pourquoi il ya encore des
climato sceptiques dans le monde et
pourquoi encore du retour d'informations
contradictoires
puis traitement mensongères qui
circulent
c'est à cause que ces industrieux si le
fond des campagnes de désinformation oui
mais oui parce que parce qu'ils y capote
aimé mais ça marche ça marche parce
qu'on aurait pu on prêt tout rouler en
électrique de plus longtemps on pourrait
tout on pourrait tout avant des panneaux
sur bath nos toits on pourrait tout à
fait se et les les panneaux solaires et
ses potes date pas d'hier
c'est une technologie ça fait longtemps
qu existe quelqu'un qui était mis en
dessous du lesotho électrique ou s'il
les autos électriques qui est nu et on
connaissait on savait que c'était
possible depuis des dizaines d'années il
ya eu des pressions qui ont fait que ça
c'est comme
ça y est tu dises ça c'est cette idée
même d au québec qui avaient des
compagnies qui voulait développer ça
combien comme 20 ans et qui ont été
obligés de fermer joyeux comme des
pressions des dix industries automobile
et le yacht est ce le cas heureusement
qui réussit est là comme tesla réussi
pour savoir s'il ya tellement précieux
il ya tellement de le bi tellement
d'argent était au pouvoir c'est très
complexe
tentant des fois dans l'espace public
des scientifiques le pojet en audio je
mets des guillemets dire qui est dans le
documentaire qu'elle écoute et la
maintenance de faire ça les grecs se
présente comme un expert comme un
scientifique un climat oppizzi
climatiques vont avoir des effets
positifs dans le monde pis les dix
matches ça va ça va amoindrir des
maladies causées par le froid c'est ok
un port pour combien de temps c'est quoi
ta c'est la bbc qui se pose est qu'il ya
encore des gens qui tiennent des
discours dit je ne peux pas dire si
j'osais qui peut pas dire non mais il ya
encore des discours l'appui le président
des états unis
dida dans des micros douter lui c'est
ouais
kate est lui qui était déjà en a été élu
justement parce que des gens qui qui
voudraient pas y croire et aux états
unis il ya beaucoup de gens qui posent
les changements climatiques tout ce que
je représente ait beaucoup de gens qui
quittaient pas qu'ils ont qui n'ont
jamais voté de leur vie se désunit
playon vitshumbi quelqu'un un personnage
qui leur ressort que des valeurs
communes
très conservatrice x qui sape qui se
voyait pas dans le paysage politique
avant le lion vitreuil qui s'en sont
allés voter pour tron pis si l'ue
augmente aux deux très bons voilà c'est
enfin quelqu'un de vrai c'est exact pour
eux c'était quelqu'un c'était quelqu'un
qui représentait enfin les valeurs
qu'ils avaient c'est fou c'est penser
penser que ce truc c'est cela c'est ça
c'est ça le problème principal que moi
je ressens par rapport aux changements
climatiques c'est quand je commence à
réfléchir au fait que peu importe nos
habitudes individuelles que la la la
balance ne revient pas à nous comment
est ce qu'on continue à vouloir changer
nos habitudes individualités mais ton
admettons le co au québec
ici on décide demain matin d'arrêter de
manger du porc par exemple voir tout ce
que ça implique pour l'environnement la
majorité du port qui est élevé ici est
dessiné en chine par deux par export
fake
même sous sa le repas l'impact
nécessaire
c'est même si 11 aux tirs mais c'est pas
ça bien tort de ne pas être cynique
puisse a bien tort de continuer à le
faire mais c'est la seule affaire qu'on
peut faire c'est quoi si c'est quoi
mettre la pression sur le gouvernement
comment tu peux le faire + tipi à quel
point mes temps cinq cent mille
personnes qui marchent dans rue avec
greater oui ça attire l'attention mais
probablement qu'il ya un un
multimilliardaire qui est acier corps
c'est un cas liste parce que demain
matin il va financer les mêmes schémas
faire les mêmes lobby bien rien qui va
réellement changer
excusez moi ce que je fais troisième ou
6 3 et vidéo sur l'environnement
de 30 minutes uniquement sur des
solutions juin avec 1.5 est un organisme
environnemental à montréal et
scientifique et qui eux m'ont aidé dans
l'écriture dans la recherche avec le
rechercher scientifique et où est ce
qu'on dit dans cette vidéo le est ce que
moi je me suis rendu compte aussi été au
fil des recherches il ya des gens des
jeux inédits des experts moi je parle du
tour l'export sur l'environnement ni
expert des activistes sur gothique s'y
intéresser au sujet mais la cites mes
activités
le mont est large je crois que mais je
me console pas du tout commence comme un
activiste piger pas la prétention de
dire si ce qui était chez moi j'aborde
plein de sujets son marché depuis jamais
je suis pas un expert mais j'essaie de
m'intéresser au sujet puis le
vulgarisateur médecins pour 10 dans
cette vidéo dans cette vidéo sur les
solutions on se rend compte qu il ya
beaucoup de groupes d'experts des gens
super intelligent dans le monde qui
travaille en ce moment pour trouver des
solutions et des gens qui sont ceux qui
connaissent extrêmement bien la
situation qui connaissent les faits qui
sont ce qu'ils se rassemblent qui tous
les solutions technologiques ou des
solutions pour les climats pis si j'en
lis qu'on le veuille ou non il ya un
espoir à travers ces gens-là tracy
groupe olympien le bouc au québec y en a
beaucoup dans le monde fait qu t il faut
pas arrêter lavaur et sport je pense que
c'est important de d'avoir espoir en
l'égérie humaine l'adaptation humain la
créativité humain je pense que si on si
on sait s'ils ont ce focus sur notre
créativité comme on le comme on le fait
pour le déjà réussi dans le procès dit
vous regardez aussi passé on est déjà
réussi à aller au delà des crises
globales sur les russies a trouvé des
solutions fake c'est pas impossible
qu'on trouve des solutions il faut
garder espoir
du moment que ces gens là ont deux ans
les financements nécessaires pour faire
ses recherches le week une fois qu'on y
est on a des solutions
ben qu'on se mette ensemble picon la
réaliste puis je pense que la difficulté
c'est que le tout le monde
si un pays aaa en voie de développement
qui nous ôtons s'est développée par le
charbon puis par toutes sortes de
des technologies zéro vertueux ça a fait
notre sens économique s'était adressé
des pays en voie de développement
puis ils nous envoient leurs spectateurs
et votre manière de faire c'est pas la
bonne fille dans l'ensemble c'est
probable c'est que même en super il a
économiquement le toit il tout à
profiter de ce répit pour com - après sa
6ème est de ramener tout le monde sous
une même bannière
même volonté de com de changer les
choses parce que c'est ça le défi
principal mais c'est pas comme si moi
j'ai les lèvres est ce qu on regorge
déjà d'idées - oui depuis de solution si
on sait que c'est con que ça existe la
dst grosse cheminée qui casper le co2
qui transforme sa aurai sont solides et
prouve qu'elle n'a pas à tous les coins
de rue humaine parce que ça reste on
essaie de trouver des trucs efficaces
par rapport à ce stade est mitigé genre
est ce que ça marche ou pas ces trucs
pour les soudures mais ça va ça marche
rythmée quelconque on déforeste bazzoli
fils ça n'a aucun bon sens et ça leur
salut je sais qu'un bon sens et à chaque
année
regardez les images satellites qui voit
il y avait un petit pot de verre là bas
maintenant sur le cbot belge parce
qu'ils s'étaient d'histoire en juin des
heurts mais c'était une forêt ça n'a
aucun sens pour faire des u20 pour faire
des deschamps la marlière nazioni c'est
sur l'a12 l'amazone ici la déforestation
pour l'agriculture à 100% sur le monde
le monde il partageait beaucoup de
séquences à brûler l'amazone icom de
quest un grand d asthme et la raison
pourquoi la manul amazonie brûlait
c'était parce qu'on mange des animaux
d'élevage deux mois de mars exact parce
qu'on mange de façon industrielle
si beaucoup l'agriculture et l'élevage
de maspie tout ce qu'il sait c'est que
ces grosses industries le de viande
c'est une des uns des gros gros gros une
des grosse partie des changements de ces
qui émettent des gaz efficace à
l'industrie du transport au complet
c'est 13%
ouais fixé c'est plus polluant que les
publions ce bateau train c'est plus pour
loire lille et après les pourcentages et
il changeait cependant des sources très
difficile d'avoir pourcentage précis
mais c'est clairement plus que les
transports en larmes en plus qui fait
que ces sept et six industries le ont
tiré le documentaire qui s'appelle
demain et on parle dans ce documentaire
d'agroécologie si de l'agriculture qui
tient compte de l'environnement de la
nature dit et qui est des fois encore
plus productives quelques l'agriculture
de masse et qui bon il ya des gens
qu'ils font mais à petite échelle et on
pourrait le faire à plus grande échelle
ça serait bon pour le climat et on
pourrait éventuellement faire mais bon
il faut que la volonté il faut qu'il
faut que les jets qui s'est réduit les
déloger ces grandes industries lot il ya
une façon d'élever le bétail qui
permettrait de resserrer le co2 dans le
sol j'ai pas exactement la science
derrière cela mais chic c'est quelque
chose qui existe siens 1-1 des
contre-arguments cancon l'ensoa à
l'abolition de la culture à nîmes lundi
sauf que pour ce genre de techniques
d'élevage le il faut premièrement clic
le bovin soit fruits un jus ce qu'on
appelle fait que pis pour ceux admettons
qu'on veut que toute la population
puisse continuer à manger du steak me
tombait que ce soit levée de cette façon
la forêt comme mangeant un steak 2 2
comme si je pensais 5 à chaque trois
mois pour que ce soit viable de le faire
infecter de dire oui mais ça peut être
fait de façon éthique ça peut être fait
de façon éthique et environnementale
mais vraiment pas dans le modèle qu'on a
en ce moment on mange trop de viande
mange trop de viande et culturellement
on mange beaucoup trop de protéines tout
on est trop moche trop le prêter à tous
les jours et c'est culturel c'est la
viande c'est culturel et et il y aurait
des façons de rééquilibrer leur
équilibre inpi le nouveau guide
alimentaire un petit peu leur
équivalence ans qui était pilote
génération manche probablement moins que
nous venons effectifs définitivement
mais reste que la consommation de viande
augmente de plus en plus demain
conscientiser de plus en plus d'humains
vegan plus en plus d'humains qui roule
électrique
il ya de plus en plus du moins points
donc on continue de produire plus mais
la planète elle a peu juste produire un
thé à peu juste soutenir un certain
rythme le facteur même si on est plus
conscientisés les faits comptent ni
juste plus bas voilà surpopulation c'est
beaucoup gens qui parlent des sports de
surpopulation
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est moi je crois
pas qu'on dise que con et surpeuplé où
convoi est surpeuplée si on regarde les
ressources fournies sur la terre on
pourrait être beaucoup plus d'êtres
humains oui sans problème sur ces
anglais george armand carrasso mais si
on mangeait pas d'animaux motion prenait
juste notre nourriture des grains on
pourrait nourrir trois fois la
population de la planète voilà fait que
c'est si le problème et spock et roux
d'êtres humains c'est qu'ils ont conser
de manière extrêmement inéquitable un
efficace aussi haut et puis au
bangladesh et surtout natalité était
beaucoup plus élevé dans les pays
d'afrique beaucoup plus élevés qu'ici
mais pollue énormément moerenhout et
nous on pollue énormément plus curieux
c'est fait c'est plus notre mode de vie
puis de la consommation qui est qui
j'ai une théorie nullement scientifique
vous lancez les gars moi que vous en
pensez que je lisais dernièrement qu'en
chine je pense que c'est ça fait 20 ans
qu'il n'y avait pas eu un taux de
natalité aussi boc lui attribue sûr
beaucoup pour changement culturel mes
attributions beaucoup à la fertilité qui
commence à être plus difficile pour les
poules et les êtres humains est-ce que
vous pensez que en chine en ce moment
l'évolution fait comme l heure cela
qu'est un peu est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une possibilité qu'il ya
l'évolution l'évolution de la musique
mais on sait le corps s'adapte mais dont
il ya du monde
nice en ce moment sans petit orteil ben
parce que le petit orteil et comme
inutile dans là qu'ils m'ont même où je
prends moi je pense pas parce que de ce
que je comprends l'évolution c'est que
l'imitation son rendement qu'est ce
mais les mutations sur weldom et à
travers le tort un travail qui ont les
mutations les plus appropriés vaut
rester plus avantageuse sauf que
aujourd'hui même c'est une mutation qui
désavantageuse pivot prenant pas mourir
non puisqu'on est dans un monde qui ont
le plus besoin de survivre
c'est ce faux pas comme quand même passé
de jeune à la prochaine génération des
jeunes ça sera peut-être plus lié à
maintenant la pollution c'est là
incroyable beaucoup à lucic et
l'excellent film de science fiction dans
le fond dans un monde où est ce que les
femmes sont plus fertiles puis pour
faire signer l'enfant le plus vieux
comme 10,80 que le film commence puis le
il ya une fille à la rive qui est genre
en serbie - blessé comme what the fuck
me le faut comme qui est protégé cette
fille leur pc comme ici dans ce monde
tout comme pathak apocalyptique vraiment
je recommence fm le incroyable mais
c'est un film aussi qu'ils traitent
d'environnement à sa manière
qui traite de du sommet web est ce pour
répondre aux questions je pense je pense
pas mais il ya aussi un phénomène que
dans les pays développés le taux
natalité diminue vraiment intelligent ou
c'est aussi l'éducation au puy la
contraception au pied puis les bises ou
cissé méthon avant ou ici on en fait
élire en famille parce qu'on a besoin de
main d'oeuvre pour la terre par exemple
où on fait juste plein d'enfants parce
que la boîte sans religion la religion
ou si des fois on reproduisait parce que
la moitié mouraient en très beaux arts
joue aussi à l'accouchement puis il a
apprécié quand la médecine qui les
avants c'est justement parce qu'on aura
trouvé ces enfants là bas le tout d'un
coup ils osent me restait tout métier
mais ceux qui avaient une pression comme
celui des enfants de deux enfants de
plus en plus j'écoutais en fait ici on
produit le podcast de garder la dot du
bourg oui qui s'appelle puis il y avait
un épisode sur la décroissance qui tout
au long dans le fond il était je me
rappelle plus le nom de la personne avec
qui et brière et m&a faingaa
bienfaisance genre de disto qui lui
disait que lui croyait pas
nécessairement à la décroissance comme
la façon de sauver la planète mais
croyait plus à la croissance
environnemental puis où est ce que je
veux en venir c'est que dans que dans
des enfants par exemple
oui beaucoup d'activistes anti nataliste
qui disent que d'avoir un enfant c'est
la chose qui est la pire pour
l'environnement ce qui est somme toute
de la façon avec laquelle on vit en ce
moment
vrai parce que si ce moment c'est parce
que si on met au monde quelqu'un qui vit
comme nous on a vécu maintenant jusqu'à
maintenant jusqu'à avant d'avoir un
éveil et environnemental mettons là mais
effectivement c'est la pire chose pour
l'environnement si absolument n'ait pas
d'impact environnement
exactement sauf que de mettre au monde
quelqu'un qui va vivre positivement pour
l'environnement possiblement que c'est
l'impact au final positif encore le
juste de vivre un impact environnemental
si quelqu'un on peut juste vive on peut
changer nos habitudes changer nos
comportements changent et plein
d'affaires mais sait on vit quand même
et en amérique du nord selon certaines
règles qui sont épris écrite l'opinion
peut pas vraiment à moins de vivre en
totale autarcie dans le bois ou le 10
mai mais sinon c'est justement juste le
fait d'être noir américain comme tu
disais tantôt au même site attention tu
pollues 100 fois plus qu'un africain
mais il faut que ça change mais ceux ci
un peu hors de notre contrôle
comme je le disais avant le podcast il
ya des habitudes qui ont qui vont juste
changer si des lois qui sait comme je
faisais la bh - systématiquement quand
je vais à l'épicerie
j'oublie mais c'est exact mais afin qu
avant je prenais des années passées
maintenant qu'il n'est plus j'en prends
plus je peux tu n'as pas exact les
habitudes c'est vraiment les gens vont
développer les habitudes les plus
faciles à développer fait qu'il faut que
les habitudes les meilleurs pour
l'environnement soient les plus faciles
à développer
donc il faut que les sacs réutilisables
ce soit plus facile à utiliser que des
sacs en plastique aux gens qu acheter
une voiture électrique ce soit plus
facile plus accessible qu'une auto et
essence et traditionnelles d'autres ses
habitudes le doivent devenir les plus
accessibles pour les jeux c'est ça votre
book
mais ça il faut que les gouvernements
les industries change pour que
d'habitude le deviennent vraiment axé
sur pied pour revenir faut se recollent
au point initial qui était de dire que
pour que ça change faut que ça devienne
vos frocs ça dérangeait monétaire parce
que je vois pas comment gouvernement
brescia sortir d'une joute de lobby oui
c'est fait il va falloir que de faire
l'alternative écologique de vienne
move monétaire mais c'est déjà un
nouveau moniteur parce que aujourd'hui
où aujourd'hui elle était pauvre trois
ans qu'est aujourd'hui on parle de
l'argent en 1 clic objectif est-il
aujourd'hui des subventions des
gouvernements dans le monde c'est 5300
milliards par année pour les
combustibles fossiles en subventions des
gouvernements 5 mai 300 milliards et
quand on regarde les énergies
renouvelables mettant les ollier c'est
moins d'un milliard par année
versus 5300 milliards il ya une énorme
problème c'est des subventions
gouvernementales c'est pas des
compagnies privées c'est des subventions
gouvernementales
fake le projet de loi donne je peux
aussi vous dire ma troisième vidéo je
parle du projet de joie des petits comme
un groupe de scientifiques dans le monde
qui sont rassemblés qui ont fait une
liste des 100 actions afin d' ordre de
priorité pour l environnement et le
projet de jardin justement parle de
décider ces subventions le et il dit qu'
on pourrait économiser le gouvernement
les gouvernements globalement pourrait
économiser et même faire de l'argent si
passer aux énergies renouvelables
ils les énergies renouvelables générer
de l'argent parce que on pas de l'argent
aujourd'hui à tous les jours avec les
subventions comme c'est facile avec tous
les coûts liés aux combustibles fossiles
de santé de d'aménagement de dormans
coûts indirects rioucourt bitume facile
on pourrait gagner de l'argent si on
faisait le changement donc six as police
ça devient ça devient presque absurde le
droit de regarder seul fils elle c'est
pourquoi c'est pas déjà fait le principe
est le même pour les subventions données
aux agriculteurs qui élèvent des animaux
gazelles énormément c'est l'état qui
paye pour ce célèbre équipe qu'on puisse
faire cette boucle parce que c'est trop
ça demande trop d'énergie trop d c'est
absurde hopper de l'argent pour polluer
moins
c'est comme un délit deux négatifs alors
qu'on pourrait gagner plus d'argent
économisé plus d'argent et en plus à lui
va des 10 élargi vertes renouvelables et
des moeurs bon agriculture élevage tout
sauf la côte basque en 50 10 d'énergies
vertes renouvelables les énergies
renouvelables l'éolien et le solaire
d'ailleurs les eaux liée au fait que
l'énergie la moins chère aux bons mots
chocs et les combustibles fossiles
dix à quinze ans c'est déjà à chaque
année ça
l'éolien et le solaire et les énergies
renouvelables en général à chaque année
le prix diminue et voilà affecter le
prix d' instaurer tout et énergie le
versus continuer d'exploiter les
cobistes facile servier beaucoup moins
cher des stores et les énergies
renouvelables maintenant epide
d'utiliser ces énergies leur à long
terme que les cocos tigre et à
s'endetter ou à payer les subventions
pour les coupes c'est facile puis tous
les cookies son relief dans le parc à ce
qu'ont eue avec avec jean martin aussant
lui il disait pierre qui avec je me gêne
qu'il disait que au québec surtout au
québec
oui on a une richesse massive d'énergies
renouvelables ou et pis on pourrait
devenir littéralement des leaders
mondiaux sur ceux sur l'utilisation
d'énergies renouvelables avec
l'hydroélectricité beaucoup et
normandeau et on est extrêmement riche
au québec à cause de ça à cause de
des cours d'eau oui à cause des énergies
renouvelables hydroélectricité mais
aussi jeux sa cause connaît une des plus
grandes réserves d'eau douce dans le
monde qui va être une ressource
extrêmement précieuse dans le futur
ouais très très riche et très bien
positionné par pauvreté au québec pour
être des leaders effectivement mais ce
qui est aussi c'est le troisième n'est
mais moi tu vois le doigt triste et je
pensais que c'était là la plus grande
fierté du québec pic st dans magnifique
il ya aussi bien il ya aussi des aspects
négatifs ouais j'aime hydro mai
beaulieu c'est disponible en podcast
puis à la télévision ça parle sur le web
aussi je pense que jean très haute et
vous c'est cette pièce est absolument
estrosi
c'est une des meilleures choses que j'ai
vu aussi ce que tu es catégories
confondues est mis droit c'est le fun
jimmy dreux 1 c'est un grand travail
crise et beaulieu qu'elle fait je
recommande à tous en podcast sous la
pièce de théâtre
et puis moi c'est drôle j'ai un peu que
la braye qu'hydro-québec encore en ce
moment je collabore produits hydro
québec pour des projets vidéo est
heureux comme il
il en fait ils sont tout à fait il
encourra quand il encourage les gens à
écouter j'ai mis deux roues ne sont pas
très bien écouter parce qu ils acceptent
ces critiques le pied même ils veulent
évoluer positivement avec puis c'est le
fun de voir qu hydro québec a accepté
d'être interviewé par ces mêmes
participants dans le truc fait qu hydro
québec c'est un parfait il ya des trucs
et parfums notamment d'exploiter de
nouveaux barrages non seulement parce
que c'est logique ou peu mais mais ils
sont ouverts à la critique
la pièce est vraiment cool je recommence
c'est une pièce juste pour la vente de
pièces qu'ils ont pratiquement quatre
heures avec avec un trac
oui moi je me suis pas ennuyé une seule
fois car à la pièce de jallet auteur
maisons neuves sur l'eau géologie tc1
mercredi soir j'avais rien je sais comme
j'ai dit je me suis vraiment fait avoir
positivement par sponsorisés sur
facebook j'enregistre au genre qui est
cette semaine mercredi algérien a besoin
en deux peuples je suis du genre des
culottes ont d'ailleurs été les derniers
dansante balcon de la pire espèce le
sait
j'étais avec la mère j'ai trois mille
abonnés sur un style iphone avec cette
pièce là c'est que c'est écrit par
quelqu'un justement qui est toutes ces
questions le sur belle parade de
personnes au québec mais juste la
conscience environnementale d'une
personne qui était moyenne
personne communauté qui peut plus
informer travers le jeu fait le parcours
avec elle attend maintenant ce voyage le
type si si si si c'est pas seulement
c'est pas juste didactique informatif le
sait c'est vraiment tuerie tu apprends
des touches et été transportée par qui
tous en même temps
mouty world trade center et veracruz
c'est tellement bien raconté pierre
alain charisme absolument incroyable
j'en ai même pas encore ça assène à
parler et a fêté comme son intro au fait
je sais déjà l'amour avec elle celle à
qui cette femme et un charisme il est
attachant des droits aux mots puis je
vais mettre mon ami tu sais pas diderot
pml ça vexe comme ses relations
amoureuses
c'est tellement bien bien raconter c'est
vraiment cool sauf qu'en bout de ligne
ça ressort que puis justement
l'information passe c'est pas trop
complexe mais petit en souviens tu sais
pas c'est pas comme au quai georges
soirée d'information puis il m'en reste
plus rien après parce que j'en ai trop
su le sait si comme je suis seul et est
l'information se fasse vite ces quatre
hommes c'est que c'est mais en bout de
ligne si une conclusion affaire c'est
que l'hydroélectricité
parce que de ce que j'en comprends que
c'est la position peu delpy de la pièce
mais c'est qu'en ce moment on finance
des barrages l'île de ré est restée à
perte
ouais on va ça nous coûte scène que je
pense c'est sylvie du point 0,08 soudi
qui du kilo à tous
puis on le vend la moitié du pire ils
font exactement en excipant table puis
là la question mais pourquoi explique
pourquoi tu vas adorer quelque chose
pourquoi dessus investir est maintenant
un milliard et 1,3
si on veut protéger le texte partie
exactement en création de barrages
électriques mais donc protégé est
expertise est donc construit des
barrages qui sont pas nécessaires et qui
ont des coûts environnementaux et pour
la nature c'est cela la critique parce
qu'on est bon on a quelque chose qu'on
doit continuer
cesari pipi deuxième chose mais on on se
dit peut-être que le marché peut être
que dans 20 ans on va continuer de
produire cette vidéo est triste
à ce prix là ça va changer mais on va le
vendre 25 cents
avec trois fois plus cher que ce qu'on a
produit mais ça c'est de la spéculation
nos cliniques et respectueux assurerait
qu'aucune des puits ont financé en
réalité puisque la pièce dit aussi c'est
qu'il est l'économie la plus grande que
tu peux faire c'est juste l'énergie que
technologique des connectiques et
utilise vos piles c'est qu'au lieu de
financer un barrage pour créer plus
énergie qui peut financer joblo que pour
vraiment beaucoup d'argent pics et
fenêtres de son appart sont tous des cas
sites énergétiques pauvres pour les
aider à la faire ses fenêtres pour qu'il
consomme moins d'énergie pour chauffer
son n'a pas exact puis en bout de ligne
tht est pas perdu d'argent
topp a perdu aucun argent puis il ya eu
moins d'énergie en belgique était
consommée c'est ce qu'on devrait c'est
d'atteindre way concernés - hydro fait
au 6e comme c'est très drôle
je présume la page facebook diderot et
comme sa page facebook hydro-québec pas
se faire graisser
ç'a vraiment tu aimes de qui que j'adore
le qui payent des gestionnaires de
réseaux sociaux c'est une page comme
ceux de ricardo
si la rampe hydro québec répond la page
hydro-québec passé vaincre ici c'est
comme des conversations ces bulles sur
la page facebook parle beaucoup
d'efficacité énergétique hydro-québec
qui ils ont quand même une grande grande
envie de promouvoir s'est aussi fait que
c'est une question du procès puis sophie
hydro-québec au pôle choix mon avis de
devenir et et au québec je peux
commenter pas le respect pour le vent ou
pour les salaires parce que c'est se
livrer mes énergies renouvelables vers
tison ils ont eu lieu hier au québec -
mais effectivement c'est en ce moment
les ollier qu'ils osent est pourtant
nécessaire ou comptable au québec mais
il pourrait l'énergie
si on réussit à bien à la capture il
avait utilisé l'énergie que le soleil
nous envoie et y tellement infiniment
gars qui il tout le temps une journée
les séries avons assez d'énergie pour
les deux lots complets pour un an pour
renouveler toute l'énergie s'est ainsi
pas la constitution avant ces
réclamations
on avait juste la capacité pis la
volonté de l'utiliser comme il faut que
la capture et comme il faut je dirais le
solaire c'est une source infinie
l'énergie 1,5 apporte tellement on avait
une chambre dans un hôtel qui était
l'hôtel rouler que sur l'énergie solaire
puis la façade de l'hôtel puis son toit
chaque balcon était couverte d'arbres
qui y avait des sketches à l'intérieur
qui qui disaient qu'ils montrer de quoi
ça pourrait avoir l'air une métropole
écologique comme ce building le puits de
vues aériennes si je pourrai pas voir
que c'est une métropole mais que hauteur
de rue
problème il ya des commerces avec des
façades couvertes de découverte d'une
vision tout était tout était à l'énergie
solaire seulement qui moi je me dis ce
puits pour revenir à la croissance
écologique ce comme tu dis c'est une
vision c'est une belle vision du futur
mais ce qui me fait le plus peur
maintenant les les films qui me font le
plus peur c'est pas les films
d'épouvanté où cela faire lol c'est
vraiment seca aux pv si non c'est non
c'est non
des films un peu le futur dystopique de
science fiction que tu te rends compte
que finalement c'est vraiment pauvre
king loin de voir ce qu'on est
maintenant laitiers xacb les lois ne le
premier blade runner le tu regarde
aujourd'hui qui reste même qu'on est pas
loin des lois noël puis c'est ça qui ne
fait pas pour ça que ça est un excellent
film d'ailleurs le premier café et le
deuxième c'est le deuxième aussi mais si
ça me fait peur puis qui le futur mam a
peur ma peur ma part mon père m'a pas
non mais pas ma peur mais le verbe
apeurés aof après le futur m apostrophe
à fond ma poche peu plus loin c'est ça
que peu importe le futur me fait peur
sauf quand je l'imaginé comme ça parce
que si je lui met une comme ça je me dis
ah on pourrait vivre vraiment
conjointement avec notre planète orient
livre s'appelle 0 police qui est un
pilier dans la philosophie vegan qui
explique comment tu peux
comment on pourrait essayer de vivre
conjointement avec toutes les espèces
animales se soient humains et non
humains pour que dans une planète tout
le monde cohabite ça c'est un peu une
vision que de dire à place de détruire
les environnements essayons de s'y
intégrer le plus possible pour que
évidemment qui avait piqué des lions qui
se promènent sur sainte catherine
mais que en plus vive avec avec les
animaux et l'environnement cpie ça ça
soit on dirait que je me dis crime de
belles visions
voilà comment le commentaire le plus
laïc et sûrement dernière vidéo les
années 2010 160 étape c'est quelqu'un
qui dit on n'est jamais si c'est drôle
parce qu on est en même temps si près de
la dystopie et de l'utopie
moi ça c'est le commentaire le plus laïc
oui j'ai vu ce commerce que c'est vrai
parce qu'on ne on eu jamais eu autant
accès à autant de ressources dans le
soin de l'humain on est et on a des
ressources incroyables technologique
l'internet et tout ce qui vient avec
ceux des ressources par rapport aux
bonds les autos électriques et la télé
georges lalande énormément de
possibilités
il ya une certaine utopie qu'on peut
imaginer
et en même temps les changements
climatiques les crises migratoires
bon là la menace nucléaire il ya des
gars ya encore beaucoup truc où on est
prêt la dystopie donc c'est comme si les
gris pour changer au tapis dystopie
dépendamment des jo et nos envies
donc à ce monde dit que l'humanité est
pas encore devenu adulte d'encore un peu
des ados cellfish le tic en plein moyen
mais qu'ils utilisent mal sais pas d'où
ça lui le nucléaire qui offre un nouveau
jouet qui capable avec une ville au
complet
oui on n'est pas collectivement match
rires d'enfants et merci merci
énormément pour ce que tu fais merci
énormément des genoux new jersey d'être
avertis à vous de gestation j'espère que
savoir fait son son budget mais j'espère
que les gens ont apprécié nos sensations
comme moi je les apprécier pauvre est
enfin continuer à faire ce que tu fais
puis ça n'en prend plus de contenus de
qualité comme ce fait je suis qu'est ce
qu'on fait roger mas chaîne youtube
c'est mon nom et mes droits je j'ai
beaucoup de projets romands or you took
vous allez peut-être voir
des projets pas casse des projets
peut-être dans d'autres médias bon on va
voir comment ça va évoluer mais comme il
parle de transition un plus pour moi un
créative sur de nouvelles plates formes
peut-être fait que on verra où ça va
évoluer mais je suis très excité de tous
et puis voilà on continue de travailler
fort j'imagine que pour avoir toutes les
infos de tes projets facebook instagram
mon facebook puis mon instagram et
abondon exact tu disais tantôt qui est
probablement certaines craintes
reconduit youtuber et françois wade veut
qu'ils qui seront probablement des feux
de porte à près de trois heures de train
depuis paris
ouais je pense pas que ça soit honte
parce que des bons tout ce contenu
de fait ce bon travail puis on va
continuer de voir je pensais pour
longtemps merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
et c'est l'inversé